How could I overcome my fear of driving
on freeways?
Well,
one of the things you could do,
this is Ellis is do a fair bit of
imagining driving on freeways and try to
make the imagining as realistic as
possible.
But then the other thing you can do is
it's again,
it's graduated exposure.
If you're afraid of driving,
go drive with someone you trust in a
parking lot on Sunday morning when
there's no one there and then drive
around the block and a street that isn't
busy and then go to a slightly busier
street and then go to a slightly busier
street and then find a highway that's
like a just a two layer so that you know
you could practice merging and that sort
of thing.
And you got to build a plan,
say with 20 degrees of difficulty with
the highest degree of difficulty,
maybe being more merging onto a busy
four lane highway.
And you could go at night and practice
merging onto the busy highway because it
won't be busy at night.
So I would say what you do is you break
it down into small steps and then
practice each step until you're bored
with the step.
And when you're bored with it,
that means you're no longer anxious
about it and don't quit.
You know,
like stick at it because it's really
useful to overcome a fear.
And once you've identified a fear,
then you've identified something to
overcome that can definitely make you
stronger.
So like,
good luck with it and get professional,
like take a driving course if you need
to as well,
and find someone to work with.
It isn't going to make you nervous and
isn't going to harass you,
but don't quit.
It's really important to overcome a
fear.
Lucked out.